a california family is celebrating the
greatest greatest gift they can imagine
this christmas
a healthy baby boy things might have
turned out far differently for the
cooper family had it not been for the
incredible generosity
of an organ donor thousands of miles
away chris martinez has the family's
emotional first meeting
with that selfless stranger look at him
so cute
it's not every day you get to meet a
real life
guardian angel there's no words that's
amazing
describe how thankful we are to you
michael
you saved our son's life it's my honor
this is the first time
chad and eileen cooper are coming face
to face with michael speck
who donated part of his liver so 10
month old jacob
could live your son's born with a
issue and then somebody from across the
country you've never
met shows up to save his life jacob was
born with biliary atresia
a rare disease of the liver and bile
ducts that can be deadly
he was getting progressively sicker he
was hospitalized with
infection prior to transplant he was
critically ill
dr yuri jenek at children's hospital los
angeles says
jacob needed a liver transplant to
survive
jacob's dad immediately volunteered to
be a donor to save his son
but after undergoing testing chad was
confronted with a diagnosis of his own
in the ct scan and the mri we found
a mass near your pelvis
and this needs to be seen right away
with chad
and eileen both unsuitable donors
doctors began the search for another
live donor
they found one weeks later nearly 2 000
miles away
in ohio 64 year old michael speck
a father and grandfather who had already
donated a kidney to a minister years
earlier
was now volunteering again to donate
part of his liver to save a stranger
the surgeon told me it was a little 10
month old baby
when i found that out i just first
started crying
in october in the middle of the pandemic
michael traveled to los angeles for the
transplant
which was a complete success he hopes
others
follow his example there's so many other
people out there that
can do the same thing i did saving a
life and forming a forever bond to be
able to donate to a child
it's a miracle oh no you're you're that
you're you're the married you're the
miracle of my friend
no no yeah it's all worthwhile
seeing you guys for cbs this morning
chris martinez
los angeles so beautiful
in november chad cooper jacob's father
underwent surgery and remove his tumor
which was not cancerous both he and
jacob are doing great
michael speck i know american hero and
he said he has four daughters
just like wow and did it traveled in the
middle of a pandemic in the middle of a
pandemic because he heard that story
and he wanted to do something about it
and he did and he saved that little
baby's life
what are we going to do for other people
today that's a good question you know
i think we got to think about that
single day every day think about what
you can do for somebody